oui parce qu'avec l'arrivée de l'argent
dans le football il ya plus en plus de
joueurs qui sont extrêmement lisse qui
se prononce sur rien parce qu'ils
veulent garder leurs contrats avec les
annonceurs la trouve ça bien qu'une
grande star même la plus grande star du
foot française qu'il allait mbappé
prennent position se mouiller un peu sur
des sujets sensibles qui t'a dit viser
d'autre chose ça très bien qui ici peut
sensibiliser les jeunes sur des sur des
sujets sensibles sans saveur ni corey
perry comme vous êtes le seul à dire non
alors moi je dis non
pour une simple raison c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui a énormément suivi qui a
beaucoup de femmes car à un moment donné
il a quand même dit la police avec non
pas contre nous
dès qu'on pardon y en a partout dans
toutes les professions chez les
policiers chez les pompiers chez les
animateurs partout était un moment donné
c'est bien de lancer ce genre de choses
mais derrière ces actions réaction c'est
clair que je préfère qu'il propose
quelque chose pour justement arriver à
mobiliser les jeunes car des choses pour
les banlieues montée des associations
qui s'engagent et qui montrent des
choses et le que juste balancer ça parce
que ça met une fois de plus du feu c'est
à dire que oui bon ballon de deux pas
rue et sur le phoning de l'huile sur le
feu car non merci
aimer c'est trop facile de balancer ça
est derrière de ne pas proposer des
solutions ag ce que je propose est ce
que je reproche au monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement il ya plus de débat
ça jouer déjà dit cent cinquante fois
les mecs qui viennent ils balancent des
trucs et ils s'en vont à manchester
hommage à notre excellent c'est un mec
formidable ah oui c'est joli comme
dirait que rien mais non mais il faut
qu'il aille plus loin s'en faut proposer
des solutions il faut des bases s'il
faut aller sur les plateaux
il faut pas juste balancer des trucs il
ya aussi une question françois non
monsieur je suis pas du tout d'accord un
an que j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour
nicolas moi je pense qu'un sportif ne
créé sa légende qu'à travers un
engagement politique est en fait
maradona vient de mourir
mais suivant la plus parlée de l'homme
c'est un que du sportif alors que
c'était un immense maps et le temps joue
en sa faveur c'est que le mec il a déjà
vingt ans il a déjà tout gagné
donc il pourrait même être aigri toucher
ces millions lebron james par exemple
qui est une méga star de la nba c'est
d'ailleurs assez marrant parce qu'ils
sont autorisés
il autorise avec leur sponsor nike
d'aller hyper loin dans l'engagement
parce qu'une marque pourrait dire un
sportif ne suis plus appartient aux mots
tu vas aujourd'hui et surtout je ne veux
pas moi un nicolas pardon de de dire ça
je ne voudrais pas qu'on pense que le
combat contre les violences policières
et autres et le combat des noirs et des
arabes
tu as reçu à plusieurs reprises la
famille souvient ici c'est la sphère de
tous et surtout ce qui me touche c'est
que griezmann aujourd'hui a eu un
engagement exactement plus fort parce
que lui s'est retiré d'un sponsor
attirer des sponsors wenn die et parce
que il a fait le lien entre wendat
ouigours et ça et ça touche le
porte-monnaie ça il faut saluer quand
même voilà et il a il a été si c'est
vrai que c'est un engagement fou mais là
il a fait quelque chose doit lui mieres
historique contre antoine griezmann
c'est une première historique en tout
cas m bape et d'interrompre justement
une rencontre officielle c'est pas lui
qui l'a interrompu c'est tous les
joueurs oui mais justement là ici à
l'aib au delà des réseaux sociaux là
c'est pas juste un simple tweet c'est
une démarche symbolique c'est une
première ce qui la fait donc là il va au
delà des réseaux de regarder l'image
d'ailleurs d'hier soir qui était
magnifique il ya des gens qui ont dit
que c'est la plus belle image du foot
voilà de ces vingt dernières années
regarder et d'accenture en réalité rien
de mieux que les actions et here on a
été actif on a montré que voilà on est
fatigué on veut plus en plus jamais
subir ça que voilà on est tous des êtres
humains et que ça c'était intolérable
on a pris la décision de rentrer aux
vestiaires on après décision ne pas
jouer franchement on était fier on était
fier parce que voilà comme j'ai dit on
veut plus laisser passer ce genre de
choses parce que à force de laisser
passer on va laisser croire que c'est
normal et c'est pas du tout normal voilà
donc ils vont tant qu'artiste vous
bouger aussi beaucoup vous vous en voyez
mais pas autant quartiers sont tant que
femme moi j'ai été élevée par des
parents qui était merveilleux qui
s'occupait des autres intensément
moi ma famille était depuis huit
générations en algérie et ils n'étaient
pas des colons ils étaient avec le
peuple
il était très unie entre eux avec les
juifs les arabes catholique et je pense
que on est tous unis on est tous pareils
en fait on a juste un problème de
communication et de langage entre les
gens et de compréhension mais le coeur
chaque être humain à être humain a du
coeur mais moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord il faut aussi se révolter mais
ce que la révolte est ce que c'est la
bonne solution est ce que la douceur et
le partage est vraiment la sincérité ne
payent pas plus je demande ça à lessines
non mais moi j'adore le sport même si ça
ne se voit pas physiquement mais j'adore
le sport et surtout
mon militantisme mais aussi de figures
sportives qui seront engagées on aime
tous je pense que je sais pas pour un
yann s'il est mohamed ali on ne saura
jamais si mohamed ali était un grand
boxeur parce que pendant sept ans il a
mis sa carrière entre parenthèses pour
ne pas s'être engagé dans la guerre de
contrôle vietnam et disait cette phrase
aucun viet congs ne m'a traité de [ __ ]
est ce que je veux dire un moment c'est
que les sportifs aujourd'hui ils ont une
puissance médiatique qu aucun média n'a
c'est à dire que juste la phrase de m
bape et ça fait plus le tour du monde
qu'une phrase de macron plus connues
dans le monde que macro mois dans ce que
pensent ses téléspectateurs sur kylie
ann m bape et regarder oui à 65%
mais oui c'est ça